robotics and biochemistry both those
today are essentially we're mainframes
were in the 1950s and the entire
personal computer revolution is
happening in both those fields and it's
gonna change the world in the next
decade it's certainly going to be the
tablet like the iPad it is going to have
such a devastating effect on newspapers
and broadcasting and how we read and
write and draw it's going to upend how
we see the world and understand the
world and therefore our societies and
democracies I think in the next decade
Wi-Fi is going to have the biggest
impact of anything you may think we've
already got it but there are many
millions of people who don't have access
to it and the larger number of people
using it the more impact is going to
have so for me although it may seem like
an old technology to geeks it's gonna be
the one that's gonna have the big impact
over the next ten years I think
the Google book scan program and what
that really means which is making all
information all knowledge available to
all people everywhere in the world for
free that will be a world changer I
believe that it will be our ability to
actually directly control the climate so
called geoengineering it's something
that we're gonna need to contend with
over the next decade the next decade is
it's gonna be genomics so every one of
us I think by the end of the next decade
will have our complete genome sequenced
and you know and so of course that's a
technology at the core but then that's
the sequencing technology then begins
the play of all the bioinformatics
technologies to try to relate that
wealth of information to phenotype and
phenotypic consequence but by a decade
from now you and I will have our genome
sequenced I'm excited about synthetic
biology creating novel life forms which
is probably going to transform not just
research but vast areas of Commerce
everything will be smart everything will
be connected but there will be a rogue
group of people who are shoe all
technology and seek to destroy it by
exploding carbon bombs that break
circuit boards I don't know we will be
healthier we will be traveling I fear a
little bit less and we will certainly be
consuming much less carbon-based
material than we do now it will be a
karma world and a vivid err world but a
slightly happier one no that's rust
bollocks AIDS that's all bollocks I
think by then it will be a planet
inhabited by fewer but wiser people I
think that
in an optimistic sense will will have
gotten over videogames who have gotten
over our reclusiveness perhaps cities
will thrive under conditions that are
less anonymous people will plant city
gardens and they'll in general cooperate
more than they do now in part because of
technology that will enhance communities
and in part because people realize that
it adds their quality of life and the
pessimistic side of me says that
technology could make us all more more
reticent and more isolated from one
another I have a rather gloomy vision on
present grounds because I think that the
new technology is enabling governments
and even commercial companies to intrude
upon our privacy in ways that are
undreamt of in previous generations
we've fought for many centuries for our
hard-won freedoms and human rights and
civil rights they're all being taken
away sometimes just with a excuse for
something like the war on terror and I
think that's going to get worse and
worse in the coming decades of course
what I hope is that people will wake up
to this threat to their individual
freedoms and liberties and will stand
firm against Big Brother and big
government and big commerce in 2050 I'm
going to be seventy years old or young
at given new technology and I expect
that my granddaughter will come up to me
with a little flower with different
colors for all the petals and she'll say
look I made this in class today by
modifying its DNA and I'm really looking
forward to that
you